WE stand with Israel
The United Kingdom stands with Israel
All these politicians
speaking in the name of their country and saying we stand with Israel;
Who is we?
How can you say we stand with Israel
when you are there to present millions of people of your country?
You have no right to abuse the power you have as a politician
when you are only employees of the people
So how can you say we stand with Israel
when the people of your country stand with Palestine?
How can you make the opinion of the country
all about yourself and your interests?
You have to remember that the people don't work for you
you work for the people
You are obliged to represent the people
And you are obliged to be the reflection of the people
Don't forget that you speak FOR the people of your country